you've been in so many extraordinary
things and your tapestry of work is so
beautiful can we celebrate it really
quickly with a behind the scenes sure is
behind the scenes is Right St
Howard okay I'm going to mention a film
you can tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind fly on thewall mement
tidbit whatever Spider-Man
3 Spider-Man 3 Spiderman 3 oh my gosh
didn't know it at the time but I was
pregnant
didn't know it and ironically my son is
blonde so he's almost 17 years old so
this was almost 17 17 years ago 18 years
ago okay uh Jurassic world I mean which
one should I pick of the
[Applause]
50 Jurassic world one thing that uh was
really um absurd and I can say this
because the makeup artist who I worked
with on Jurassic world is here today her
name is Vivian Baker yes yes and she
also did Spider-Man as well
and so um on in this movie there was a
scene that was cut where I smear
dinosaur poop all over myself and like
the funny is that I go too far and um
and so then Vivien the had to figure out
like if because we kind of were like we
think that scene's going to be cut but
what if it's not and so she was like how
can we tell this story without you with
dinosaur poop on your face for the rest
of this movie and still have it work and
she that's why she's an Oscar winner and
it worked out and yeah so youd see it
kind of disappear but yes okay last
Twilight you just throw a little
Twilight in
there Twilight Twilight okay so I I was
a crazy Twilight fan and so yeah just
you know getting to be in Twilight was
was totally totally totally a kind of
crazy surreal experience uh probably the
most the most dangerous day on that set
was I like we got to learn the vampire
run which is basically like you know Tom
Cruz like in every movie I wait for the
Tom Cruz run and I'm never let down yeah
and that's and if and basically if you
look at the vampire run it's the same
exact run as the Tom Cruz run it's like
as fast as humanly possible with those
steady arms yes yes pumping pumping
pumping and um and so I was doing the
vampire run on a treadmill uh that was
attached to uh the back of a truck that
was driving very fast through the forest
and I remember doing this run and being
like and then the like the the car is
just going so fast and I was tied onto
this thing and I was like it's okay if I
go this way like this is pretty cool
like this is you know a great story but
uh yeah yeah dangerous dangerous running
vampire running through the forest I
like your mindset this is a great way to
go if it's going to happen it's going to
happen you know well in honor of being
here to talk about about Argy is it true
that you brought something cat related I
have something um uh do you have a cat
named Peach yes I have something for
peach you do yeah and Peach loves it
already how do
you no no
no you oh oh my God Peach is in there
you guys
yep you yep here's Peach right here
yep you
guys I
cannot believe this is this why everyone
thinks that Taylor Swift has something
to do with the movie She us to carry she
does carry these on her back with her
cats um Olivia Benson and Meredith gray
I am such a Swifty it's insane yep
like everybody thinks that she secretly
wrote the script she didn't she's maybe
Ellie she's not but she's not um Matthew
vau saw a picture of Taylor Swift with a
backpack and so um and so yeah in large
part that was inspired by Taylor Swift
is it true that Claudia Schiffer and
Matthew Von's cat is the cat in the film
yes yes totally sorry oh my God baby by
the way have you ever met Taylor Swift
in real life no I wish I saw her in a
room once
but but no she's amazing I know she's so
special and she's such a positive
influence and it's another kind of
person who she's she's so powerful but
the way in which she wields her power is
with genuiness and she's not trying to
be cool yeah Bry Dallas Howard I cannot
love you more it is crazy I am playing
it cool but Argy isn't theaters and IMAX
oh I suggesting an IMAX that's a visual
Feast visual feast and it will also be
streaming globally on Apple TV plus soon
once it's done the Peters we'll be right
[Music]
back